we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail from a very very angry troy
York who's really pissed off that I
didn't cover a story that I actually
covered last week
let's take additional control the man
was at at fresh kitchen
I believe his name's Eric Sprott in
midtown Manhattan and she hears though
these fans people not speak Spanish and
I was wondering if a hit home with you I
thought maybe she did say nothing cuz
you look like a buddy of yours in here
drinking pal of yours Backman yeah she
looks like someone you would hang out
with and yeah basically I think hip call
Nazi workers and threatening to call the
CIA and ice and is a good idea Pakman
because these people if you're not
speaking English and learning English
then what are you are you trying to
assimilate are just being colonists I'm
a cultural jingle 11c just waiting for
you to talk about this jocular burger
this Jewish lawyer in midtown Manhattan
I bet he's a buddy you thank me okay
Troy York of course missing that I
covered the story last week so I did
talk about it he seemed to be on
something during that voicemail that was
an unusual rambling voicemail even even
for Troy York standards but I talked
about the story last week buddy not not
not a story that I missed and his name
is uh late Aaron Schlossberg it wasn't
Eric I think was Aaron Schlossberg okay
we've got a great bonus show coming up
for you today access the bonus show by
being a member at join pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show the world famous bonus
show coming up next